Ask anyone who has ever lived in a small town
and they’ll most likely all tell you the
same exact thing: The worst part isn’t just
being far away from the nearest city, or distant
from friends and family.
It’s the boredom that gets you, having so
little nearby gives you so few options for
things to fill your time with.
For some, they get used to it.
As they grow old, spending their life in the
same tiny community, they either learn to
make their own entertainment or just get used
to the boredom, drowning it out by sitting
and watching TV all day.
But others, they just can’t stand being
bored, being stuck somewhere with nothing
interesting to do, and ultimately, they can
end up getting so sick of it that there’s
only one option: leave.
Pack their bags and hit the road, up sticks
and move to a new place far from the small
town they were born in.
Thing is, leaving isn’t cheap.
Moving to a new town, a big city or even an
entirely different state is a luxury that
costs a pretty penny.
Some might work, and save their wages until
they can realize that dream of moving away.
But not everyone has that much patience, some
want to be free of the boredom as soon as
they can.
Maybe they might apply to be a contestant
on a game show, chance it all and try to win
themselves a big cash prize.
Sure, it’s a hell of a gamble, and a loss
might mean humiliation in front of everyone
you kow and more, but winning could be your
ticket away from small-town living.
That might be easier said than done though.
Not only does someone looking to move away
need to be picked as a contestant, they also
need to play by the rules and actually win
the game.
But as if that wasn’t enough, they also
have to live to tell about it…
For as long as she could remember, Kat had
always hated it here.
Her hometown was tiny, too small to include
more than the main street with few local stores,
the one school that everyone who had ever
lived there had studied at, and little else
of note.
And as for things people could do for fun
in town?
Well, as you can probably imagine, the options
were severely limited, especially for a group
of teenagers like Kat and her friends.
Most of the time all that she and the others
– Leo, Ricky, and Dani – could do to pass
the time was sit in the back of Ricky’s
truck and park in the middle of town, watching
people and waiting for something even mildly
interesting to happen… not that it ever
did.
The four of them had a name for the rest of
the townsfolk, everyone that had lived there
for their entire lives and never dared to
venture anywhere else; ‘lifers’, as in
they were imprisoned, serving a life sentence
in this small town, never to escape or move
on or make something of themselves.
As much as they liked to poke fun at those
people, each of the group knew that every
weekend they wasted just sitting around, the
closer they were getting to one day becoming
lifers themselves.
“We need to just go,” Kat would say, trying
to rally the other three into taking a spontaneous
trip away as a group.
“Just load the truck up one day, pick a
direction and drive until we find somewhere.”
Ricky and Leo would nod their heads in agreement,
and Dani would talk for hours about all the
places she might like to go one day, but none
of them ever actually made any plans to leave.
Nobody knew where to start… until they heard
rumors about an abandoned TV studio just outside
of town.
Apparently, according to Dani’s older brother,
it had been there for years, just sitting
there completely empty.
It wasn’t just a small local studio either,
one of the big national networks had owned
it and used to film there regularly back in
the day.
“Why would someone set up a studio here
of all places?”
had been Leo’s immediate response.
“Look at where we live,” Kat replied.
“It’s the literal middle of nowhere, the
network must have got the land dirt cheap.
The real question is, why don’t we go and
check it out?”
“What for?”
Dani asked.
Kat silently gestured at the cramped main
street that surrounded them, the place that
may as well have been the center of the known
universe to the four teenage friends.
“Do you see anything else to do around here?”
Before long, the four of them were in agreement.
Ricky’s truck pulled up in front of their
houses in the middle of the night, and under
the cover of darkness, they drove out towards
what was left of the TV studio.
This was it, they were finally going somewhere
beyond the choking, cramped confines of their
tiny hometown…
although whether or not they’d all make
it back was another matter.
Here’s a hard lesson for you, kids: You
can’t fight for the life you believe you
deserve if you don’t have a little skin
in the game…
With home a few miles in the rear-view mirror,
the truck stopped at a chain-link fence.
A pair of signs were hanging from it; one
welcoming them to the studio, while the other
simultaneously warned them to keep out, that
this area was private property.
Ignoring it, the four of them stepped out
of the truck and started to climb the fence,
throwing Leo’s jacket over the top to avoid
injury.
Beyond the fence was a huge building, almost
the size of a warehouse, with a door marked
‘Studio Entrance’ that practically invited
the intrepid teens to open it up and have
a look inside.
Each one of them carrying a torch in hand,
the group walked up to the abandoned studio
and gently pried open the door, trying not
to make too much noise.
Even though they knew the whole place was
abandoned, they still didn’t want to attract
too much attention and get caught trespassing.
The lights were all dead as Kat led the group,
her hand being tightly squeezed by Dani next
to her, the two boys behind.
None of them had been sure what to expect,
it wasn’t exactly like anyone in the group
had ever set foot inside a TV studio before.
But they were met with a narrow, concrete-walled
corridor, so underwhelming that it almost
made it extraordinary in just how profoundly
dull it was.
Lifting his torch, Leo pointed out some lettering
on the wall that read ‘To TMDG Set’, with
an arrow pointing them four friends further
down the corridor.
Naturally, driven by her curiosity and need
to be literally anywhere apart from her hometown,
Kat followed the arrow’s direction to another
door.
Pushing it open, she stepped inside, her torchlight
immediately being blocked by a thick curtain.
Brushing her hand against the material, she
started looking for a parting.
But before she could…
“Welcome, contestants!”
a voice boomed through the dark, coming from
somewhere in the space beyond the curtain.
Instantly, Dani screamed at the sound, almost
wrenching Kat’s arm off in sheer surprise.
“Before we begin,” the voice continued.
“I need you all to tell me, are you ready?”
Kat shot a look back at Ricky, the friend
furthest behind her.
Fumbling with the door they’d entered through;
it was locked, he couldn’t get it to budge.
He turned and met Kat’s gaze, shaking his
head.
“Sure, we’re ready,” Leo suddenly piped
up, calling out to answer the voice.
Before the rest of the group could turn and
glare at him, the curtain around them lifted.
So much bright light came pouring in that
it practically dazed the four of them, each
taking a moment to readjust.
When her vision cleared, Kat saw they were
standing in a huge sound stage, blinding spotlights
pointing at her and her friends from somewhere
above, with a seating area big enough to seat
their town’s entire population.
“In that case, folks, you know what time
it is,” came the voice again, talking as
if there was a live studio audience present,
despite every chair being unoccupied.
“These four lucky challengers will go head-to-head,
each one looking to take home the victory
as well as a huge mystery prize.
But only if they dare to take on The Most
Dangerous Game!”
There was a pause, as if this unseen announcer
was waiting for a round of applause.
Without warning, more lights came on, illuminating
the space in front of the four very confused
friends.
Standing before them was what looked like
part of an obstacle course, a series of four
horizontal beams over an empty space.
The glare of the light was so intense that,
even squinting, Kat couldn’t tell what was
beneath.
It just looked like a void, nothing but total
darkness with four narrow beams bridging the
gap between where they stood and another platform
beyond.
“Well, what are you all standing around
waiting for?”
the announcer declared, almost mocking the
four teens, urging them on.
“Oh, the rules, of course!”
There was another awkward pause, like the
voice was waiting for laughter.
“It’s simple, the four of you will be
competing to make it through each of our obstacles.
Make it to the end before the timer hits zero,
and you’ll be tonight’s big winner!
But fall behind, or cheat, and it’s out
with you!”
A huge digital countdown illuminated on one
side of the sound stage, telling the group
they only had ten minutes to play.
Kat, Leo, Dani, and Ricky barely had a chance
to question what was going on, exchanging
quick, concerned looks before the announcer
started urgently counting them down.
“Three, two… one!” he cheered.
Simultaneously, the four teenagers felt a
presence looming behind them, like a figure
was standing just out of view, blocking them
from turning back.
Carefully putting one foot in front of the
other, Kat started shimmying along the beam
in front of her, trying to keep herself steady
while also moving as fast as she could without
falling.
Out of the corner of her eye, she could see
Dani on the beam next to her, doing the same
but finding it a little easier to balance.
Leo was having no problem at all, sidestepping
with enough speed to keep him practically
neck and neck with Kat.
But Ricky, he was wobbling.
Every foot he placed on the beam, he felt
like it might give way beneath him.
But it was just a game show, right?
Sure, it shouldn’t even really be running
right now, but regardless of why or how, the
worst that could happen was that he would…
fall.
His next step missed the beam entirely, and
Ricky could feel himself toppling.
“Guys!” he called out to his friends,
trying to shift his weight onto his back leg.
Kat, Dani, and Leo all froze and snapped their
heads back to look at him, just in time to
see Ricky wildly flailing his arms.
His whole body toppled to one side, and he
dropped off the beam with a loud scream.
Not one of them saw him land, or even heard
it for that matter, it was as if Ricky had
just been swallowed up whole by the dark void
beneath them, his scream getting more and
more distant until it couldn’t be heard
anymore.
“Ooh, tough break!
Talk about falling at the first hurdle,”
the voice exclaimed, as if what had just happened
was some kind of joke.
“So long, Ricky, we hardly knew you!”
Staying perfectly still, but clearly distressed,
Dani called out Ricky’s name.
There was no answer.
Kat just stared, wide-eyed at the abyss below,
only looking away as she heard Leo jump the
last bit of his beam onto the platform.
“Dani, come on,” Kat whispered to her
friend, who looked back at her with tears
streaming down her face.
The pair of them carefully stepped further
along their respective beams, trying to stop
themselves from looking down, or at the huge
clock, seconds ticking away and putting them
under even more undue pressure.
Reaching the other side, Dani dropped to her
knees, unable to hold back her sobbing.
Kneeling down to comfort her, Kat looked up
at the sound stage’s bright lights for any
sign of who was putting them through this.
“Bring Ricky back!” she yelled.
“I’m sorry,” the announcer replied,
the game show bravado dropping from their
voice, “But you agreed to play.”
“He’ll be fine,” Leo said.
“Bet you anything he just screamed like
that to scare us.”
“Leo, you don’t seriously believe that?”
Kat asked as she helped Dani stand up, wiping
her friend’s tears away.
“Is he dead?”
she sobbed.
“I… don’t know,” Kat replied honestly.
“Of course, he’s not,” Leo interjected.
“It’s a sound stage, it’s not like this
place is dangerous.”
“Then why was it abandoned?”
Dani asked.
Leo didn’t give her an answer, either because
he was distracted by the lights coming up
on the next part of the obstacle course, or
because he didn’t know and wouldn’t admit
it.
Ahead of them was a long stretch of the course,
forming a narrow, square-shaped walkway.
Wide portions of the top side were dropping
to the bottom in regular intervals, separating
the tight space before opening it up again.
Every time the segments lifted up, the three
remaining contestants could see all the way
to the other side of the walkway, where a
new platform waited for them.
With Dani under one arm, Kat looked at the
far end of the walkway as it disappeared and
reappeared behind the rising and falling segments.
Then she noticed the timer, the seconds rapidly
ticking down.
But Leo had noticed that too, and turned to
look at the two girls with a determined expression.
Kat shook her head at him, but it was too
late.
With all his strength, Leo shoved Dani and
Kat, both of them landing flat on their backs
on the platform.
He bolted towards the walkway as fast as he
could, managing to dodge between each portion,
pausing as they came down, only to run into
the next one as they lifted back up.
Helping Dani back to her feet, Kat ran after
Leo.
He already had a head start, and would easily
make it to the other side of the walkway before
the girls.
So instead, Kat held Dani close and took it
slow, methodically waiting for each segment
to lift back up before they went further into
the next safe zone.
They were gaining on Leo, who was sprinting
to the finish between the rise and fall of
the ceiling’s crushing weight.
Kat watched him disappear behind each block,
only to see his back when it came back up.
He had made it to the platform opposite, panting
but otherwise unscathed when she next lost
sight of him.
That’s when the announcer spoke up again:
“Now, now, Leo,” it said.
“That was hardly fair, was it?
And we all know what happens when you break
the rules.”
As the segment in front of her and Dani rose
again, Kat caught sight of Leo just ahead…
but it was what was standing behind him that
stopped her in her tracks.
Two huge figures, each like a shadow without
anything casting it, towered over Leo.
One of them reached forward and grabbed him,
shrouding him in a cloak of darkness… and
he was gone.
Just like Ricky, he vanished.
Kat had been so transfixed by what she’d
just witnessed that she didn’t notice where
she was standing…
right under a block that was about to drop.
Grabbing her hand again, Dani pulled her out
of the path of the descending slab.
Kat felt it brush against the back of her
leg just as the pair of them made it out the
other end and onto the platform, the last
two contestants.
“And then there were two!”
the announcer cheered, pausing again for a
reaction from the empty room.
“We don’t want to play this sick game
anymore!”
Dani yelled.
“Well, you’ve made it this far,” the
unseen host replied.
“Time for our third and final challenge,
the final stretch of the course.
Make it through this and you’re home free!
But fail, or break the rules like Leo, and
you’ll be disqualified.
Game over!”
“It’s okay, Dani,” Kat whispered.
“Whatever’s next, we’ll get through
it.”
“Do you think the boys will come back if
we do?”
her friend asked.
Just like Leo had, Kat didn’t answer.
The lights revealed the last stretch of the
course.
The final platform was overhead, a net climbing
wall in front of them.
It was a straight, vertical ascent up, with
a wall behind the next, and holes in its surface.
Wasting no time, both Kat and Dani started
climbing up the rungs of thick rope, staying
level with each other as they went higher.
“And they’re off, look at them go, ladies
and gentlemen,” the announcer commentated,
still speaking as if to an audience.
“But it’s not going to be so easy.”
The sharp sound of metal made both girls gasp,
as long spikes shot forward from the holes
in the wall.
The blades retracted, fortunately having missed
Dani and Kat… this time.
What had started as a simple climb up had
become something akin to a twisted game of
Whack-a-Mole, with each of them trying to
avoid staying in front of the holes in the
wall for too long.
Dodging the spikes as they went in and out,
they climbed higher and higher until…
“Kat!”
Dani screamed.
She looked over her shoulder, only to notice
she was in the lead.
Below her, Dani was calling up to her with
a fear-stricken expression.
Her foot was caught in the rigging of the
net, kicking and thrashing wildly to try and
free it.
Kat looked back up; she was almost at the
platform, close enough to nearly reach it
with her fingertips.
But behind her, her friend was stuck and with
no idea when the spikes would next come shooting
out of the wall…
Kat threw herself over the edge of the platform
and landed on her back, just as she heard
the gut-wrenching sound of the spikes extending
ring out.
She was beside herself, tears streaming down
her face; it wasn’t uncommon for people
to be overwhelmed to the point of tears at
the end of a game show.
But Kat wasn’t crying with joy.
“We have a winner!”
the disembodied voice declared, barely audible
to the surviving contestant as she wept.
After she’d finished explaining what had
happened to the police, a group of mysterious
agents flocked to the sound stage to lock
it down, stopping anyone else from getting
close to it.
They’d found a VHS tape in the mailbox at
the front office of the studio.
On it was a recording of a game show, a live
audience cheering as one by one, Ricky, Leo,
and Dani failed to complete the course.
One of the SCP Foundation agents had come
to interview Kat, asking her to recount the
whole story all over again.
Her account lined up perfectly with everything
seen on the tape.
Then the agent asked her what her prize had
been after she won.
“A car,” Kat replied.
“The four of us always wanted to leave home.”
Now go and check out “SCP-2030 LAUGH IS
FUN” and “SCP-1733 SEASON OPENER” for
more televised tales of terror and chilling
channels of chaos to keep you glued to the
screen!